So my biggest problem was,
dude,
I looked up to you like you were my fucking idol growing up.
And then for this to happen,
I was just like,
fuck.
Why is my brother one of those assholes,
you know?
Uh,
my name is Devin.
I'm Kelly.
My relationship with my brother is old,
best friend,
new best friend.
My relationship with Kelly is humble.
The big brother,
uh,
seeking had venture partner.
When you're ready,
I am a positive person.
Yes or no?
One,
two,
three,
a surprise.
I think you're both,
I mean,
there's levels.
I'm positive with other people.
I like to hype.
I'm a hype man.
Your hype man.
I like tie people up.
So yeah,
I'm positive when it comes out words,
but
you know,
I see people around you and no one's like,
oh,
I don't want to hang around Kelly.
She's negative people like hanging around you and being around you.
So
I have felt judged by you.
One,
two,
three.
I was present.
I won.
I felt judged by you.
All right,
go on.
Always felt judged by you.
Uh,
you didn't even want to hang out with me.
God is really critical on you.
I know,
I'm very aware and all my friends and they're very aware.
I was critical of your friends too.
Oh yeah.
Everyone could see the judgment all over you
and just exuberated judgment on us.
Interesting.
I totally judged you at one point when judging you right now,
dude,
we're wearing the same color shirt.
Lights off.
I feel understood by you.
One,
two,
three,
out of everyone in the world said by you the most,
even with that whatever gap,
15 years,
how long did we not
know?
Um
hmm.
So Deb and I were really close growing up.
Uh,
I mean,
I dunno,
we wait.
We went separate ways.
Uh,
I,
uh,
I took a very dark path.
I got into drugs in high school.
Um,
I had a disgusting that I just couldn't get out of Devin went to school and was
in a serious relationship and,
uh,
I don't know.
We,
we,
we took very different paths.
Yeah.
So we didn't talk though.
That was like,
yeah,
he told me,
fuck myself.
Those are the only words you said.
Two years.
Mom told us we had to say hello to each other
and we,
we met on the stairs and he just screamed in my face
and then I left and I left.
When did you leave?
17 moved out,
Steve.
But anyway,
we didn't really talk and I was going through something weird and I told my mom,
I'm going to go to Amsterdam.
I booked my ticket and I'm leaving.
And she goes,
ask [inaudible] if he wants to go with you.
I'm like,
uh,
no.
Asked Devon four months ago with you.
I thought about it and I was like,
actually,
yeah,
let's see what's up,
what he's doing.
So I called Devin and it was like,
hey mom,
mom wants me to ask you to come to answer down with me and I'm starting to
believe I can't go alone.
Uh,
what do you,
what are you doing?
We fucking did it.
It was a crazy,
crazy experience.
And we've been,
we've been communicating a lot recently.
Devins a good support system for me.
Likewise.
So it's cool.
We're friends again.
Yeah.
You Ready?
I'm ready.
That's me.
Yeah,
that's true.
Hmm.
I am a good person.
All right.
One,
two,
three.
Yeah,
I've been told the last like three years.
I'm no horrible person.
Um,
and you start to believe that stuff when you're told that over and over again.
But
there's no way I'm a bad person.
I care so much.
You're not the worst.
You're not the worst person and not the worst person.
I think you are a good person because I've seen people talk to you and,
and tell me afterwards how much,
how easy it is to talk to you,
how easy you are to be around and people gravitate towards you.
Okay.
You care about people.
And I are authentic person.
Kelly Maca low.
That's funny cause that's what people say about you.
I think you're a good person.
I think we get lost.
We get lost in our heads.
We are so judgmental of ourselves.
I'm like,
those couple of years after you're divorced and stuff that was rough and like I
could see where where you might not have felt
super amazing at that moment.
Are you doing with that?
It's a tough one.
For years,
I was with somebody who was my best friend ever know and they're just something
else that I wanted in life.
And for that to be in question and I don't really have all the answers for
everyone.
It felt like I was Kinda in this quarter law where you know as judged a lot and
I get it.
So my biggest problem was,
dude,
I looked up to you like you were my fucking idol growing up.
And then for this to happen I was just like,
fuck,
why is my brother one of those assholes?
You know?
And that's Shitty of me cause we don't know what's going on in other people's
lives.
I
broke my heart that I was such a Dick to you.
I'm glad we're getting closer.
One,
two,
three.
Okay,
we're in agreement.
It's nice to have a friend.
It's nice to have somebody who understand you.
It's great to have a totally be like again,
a little bit by my family.
Um,
you on the outs for a whole like three years.
So calm down,
Bro.
You were out for a little while.
If Kelly can get that or the family.
Oh Man.
Mine's going to be easy.
Be Easy.
Uh,
do family's so important.
It's so important.
Hmm.
I took it for granted growing up.
Yeah.
Well I'm glad we're closer.
You and I am glad to,
uh,
like you and I have an unspoken understanding at times.
I don't even think it needs to be a conversation,
but there's an element of no matter what we've gone through,
um,
having like that,
kind of like wink of an eye and that oil like underlying understanding
you.
Okay.
We're going to be able to do something to your amber.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's see what we can do it.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
All
right.
I used to tell a got it.
He's still got it.
Yeah.
Glad we're talking.
Yeah,
that's not
nice again.
Hey,
did you see that new job leave video?
Yeah,
we just put it out.
It's pretty good,
right?
What do you hold on a second.
Hey everybody,
hope you liked that video.
If you did,
please subscribe to our channel for more.
You can also watch it.
Some of our previous work here.
Please check it out.
Thank you guys,
and we'll see you guys next time.
Sorry,
get back to this.
Are you still there?
Yeah.